well you know that those shows you have
Bobby sorry baby
are you [ __ ] Putin over there sorry
don't put in here dude
with this stuff I just do thank you but
why it's America I don't have a choice
choice I'm in love are you bought I love
not you [ __ ] you are you bought are you
is this pay you know how much money that
would cause from China yes China how
much at least 80 bucks 80 bucks 80 bucks
yeah I'm Chinese made I'm a replicant
eighty bucks yeah that sounds like a
ripoff and they and they held on what I
did when they were gonna pay me there
was so much paperwork to fill out we
have to start paperwork when you do
television have to do an i-9 aw9 of
start form on a consent form a jokes
deliver form what Bobby looked at all
the sheets and said yeah I don't wanna I
don't want the money if I have to fill
these out and ones like you don't get
paid if you didn't want to fill them out
but I mean it was like fifteen [ __ ]
sheets of paper here daunting for him
his eyes got I got watery he got nervous
yeah for sure would rather leave a a car
in the middle of the freeway because of
the flat tire he would rather leave it
there and buy a new car the next day
then call triple-a sure yeah that for
you understand that logic I don't know I
am a human I would operate functionally
and be like hey I need to get my car
fixed I wouldn't leave a [ __ ] car in
the middle you would do that you just
give it up and I want to say this I
haven't done that in a while so most
people have never done it I know but
when that happened the first time baby
one incident happened I had no money I
was eating BRC burritos from that's not
true because on my birthday three years
ago on my birthday I remember this we
broke down on Cahuenga Boulevard and I
had a triple a card and he said put that
away let's just walk out of here let's
just take a cab home and I said what the
[ __ ] are you saying yeah I have a
triple-a card he's like I don't even
know what that is was just called
Clinton and we'll figure it out tomorrow
let's just go home
why would you do that why is that your
logic by the way that's three years ago
how do you have a car that breaks down
in the financial status that you have
you're gonna own a piece of thing that
could break down
[Music]